Tony Dungy here on the Rich Eisen show
my friend from Sunday Night Football
here he is on the program how are you
coach hey rich doing great how are you I
am doing just fine here in the Valley of
the Sun what are you expecting tonight
Tony you know what I think we're going
to see two desperate teams I think this
is a watershed game for both teams in
terms of the 2017 season Seattle losing
a game at home that they don't normally
lose with this defense letting them down
last week they know they've got a
bounce-back
Arizona trailing both Seattle and the
RAM if they're going to do it this year
they've got to make a stand at home so I
think you're going to see desperation
football and I'm excited yeah I mean and
and then you know you've got Adrian
Peterson getting the ball 30-some odd
times a game knowing Ariens as well as
you do do you expect to see something
like that tonight against a Seattle
defense that doesn't have a real Thomas
and on the back end in the middle I do
expect to see that because Arizona knows
how to place the L and when they've had
success against Seattle in the past it's
been taking Seattle's front seven out of
the picture by running the ball right at
him and whether it's David Johnson and
they've had numerous backs but in the
last three or four years when they've
beaten Seattle it's been with a physical
run game without carson palmer that
becomes even more important can they
wear seattle down and get to them in the
second half with the strong physical run
that's why they got Adrian Peterson
that's why he's here and even though
it's on three days rest I've been with
Bruce Arians before and I know first is
going to tell them we need you you got
to do it and Adrian ascends that that's
why I'm here
I know exactly right what what based on
you've seen what has makes Seattle's
offense so inconsistent based on what
you have seen well it's their offensive
line plays they really do not have a
dominant just consistent running game so
there are times when they're going to
get some runs but in order to score it
has to be passing game every
but I know that and so people are coming
after Russell Wilson the protection
hasn't been great but some way in the
third and fourth quarter Wilson has been
able to dial up these fantastic plays
and make things happen that is going to
be the challenge tonight for Arizona not
only rushing him in the first quarter
but rushing him in the third quarter and
then when you're tired after after 40
passes or 35 passes can you get those
rushes in the last three to four minutes
of the game when you need them I know my
partner riding here since feels like
there's gonna be a lot of blitzing
trying to not let Wilson run around and
where that defensive line down but make
him throw the ball fast get it out of
his hand and that's one way to
counteract all the kind of
improvisational plays the ruffle makes
Tony Dungy here on the Rich Eisen show
when's the first time you met Larry
Fitzgerald the first time you ever met I
met Larry when I was an assistant coach
with the Vikings so it would have been
like 93 94 Larry's dad was a radio
broadcaster covered the team Larry was
always coming out to the training camp
and practices he was a young high school
receiver at the time and you could tell
he had the drive to be be great and just
the type of individual that he is yeah
yeah I mean his family great great
family great mom and dad raised the
right way leader always had goals always
wanted to be a great teammate I think
you see that and the way he blocks one
of the best blocking great receivers
that you're going to find but that's
important to him to do everything right
to be part of the community not just
play on Sundays but do everything right
during the week as well and that just
goes back to the way he was raised let's
talk about some other issues in the five
minutes we have left here on the show
how long was your week after remarks
were attributed to you on Dan Patrick
show that I was disappointed to
Deborah's really making it seem that Jim
Irsay made a statement
to me about Andrew Luck and it just
wasn't true I was referring to
statements that the Jim made earlier
that yes Andrews got a rehabilitation
process he had a surgery he's got to be
mentally ready to go to make sure that
he feels confident that he can go out
there in place so this is what what's
coming and the Colt didn't expect that
they thought luck was going to be ready
and they had to go out and get Jacoby
percent so Dan and I are talking about
that and people built it into something
that it wasn't is very disappointing so
what can you read the tea leaves as to
what just happened with Vontae Davis in
Indianapolis where where he says he's
hurt and the team said it was a a
playing um a drop off and now he said
III really don't know I just followed it
from outside like you are he doesn't
make a trip they say it's not injury
related than it is and is related and
now it's play related and now he's
having a season-ending surgery I guess
so following from afar yeah it is just
it's hard to figure so I'm not aware of
what's going on there okay what was the
last time you spoke with Colin
Kaepernick coach I
I spoke to Colin Kaepernick one time I
actually interviewed him for football
night in America when we had them on the
year that they were playing great in San
Francisco seemed like a great young man
the sky was the limit there they're
winning and moving forward and then
that's the last time I've actually
spoken to him coach Harbaugh leaves
things have you know gone in a lot of
different directions so I have not
spoken to Colin Kaepernick that would be
probably three years now well I know
that you you and Rodney had an
interesting conversation on Sunday Night
Football after after the Dolphins
Raiders game about a Kaepernick which
team do you think would have different
fortunes this year if they had signed
Colin Kaepernick and had him on their
roster not just maybe during the season
but during the during the offseason
which team do you think would have a
different fortune in that direction I
don't know that they'd have a different
fortune but I really thought Seattle was
going to be a place where maybe he would
go when you have an offense that is
taking shape and you want to
back up quarterback they can do some of
the things Russell Wilson do and I made
the point on the show that now that
Houston's offense has taken this turn
and and put deshaun Watson in charge and
the things that they're doing with the
read option mobile but pockets moving
the pocket around and the quarterback
running then you want someone who can do
that if that's going to be your
offensive structure and to me I thought
they should look at Colin Kaepernick and
if they had done that maybe they'd have
a different force and now that Watson is
hurt if they had Kaepernick there and on
the roster and able to plug in they
continue to be able to do the things
that have generated these 30 and 40
point games for them coach I'll see you
tonight on the pregame and then
obviously halftime and beyond good
hanging with you last night yeah looking
forward to a rich okay Tony that's
that's Tony Dungy for more Rich Eisen
show tuned - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Rich Eisen show
app